we just got apple's brand new ipad air 5
and in this video we're going to answer
a huge question is it worth actually
upgrading to the ipad air 5 or those who
don't have it should you actually just
buy the ipad air 4 because you can get
it for only 500
brand new on amazon or even 470
renewed using our link in the
description and the way we're going to
figure out which one to buy is by
literally comparing everything to see
all the differences between the
performance the speaker quality
microphones cameras literally everything
so let's get right into it the first
thing i want to compare is the design
and obviously they look almost identical
and the only thing i see that's
different is actually the ipad air text
on the new model compared to the old one
which just says ipad now going over to
the top they both have the same speaker
grille layout everything looks identical
and they both have the touch id power
button and i think they're both on the
same standard and then going over to the
bottom we have the same speaker grilles
however the new ipad air 5 actually has
a faster usb type-c port it's actually
10 gigabits per second compared to five
on the old one now moving over to the
front the displays are actually
identical same resolution same bezels no
differences in terms of brightness but i
am seeing a little bit of a difference
in the camera sensor which i'll get to
in just a minute now both of these have
64 gigs of storage but i am curious to
see if there's a difference in terms of
the storage speed so let's go ahead and
run jazz disk bench and wow this is
actually a massive difference in terms
of the sequential read speed it's 88
faster on the new ipad air 5 but the
write speed is insane 3.3 times faster
write speed and in case you're wondering
why it's that much faster it's because
the new one has the faster usbc port so
it needs the extra storage speed and
another difference is actually the
latency that's 63 percent less latency
with the new one and now the next thing
we're going to be testing out is the
speakers because apple usually ups the
speakers with new models especially on
their iphones and we did notice that the
ipad pro speakers are much better so
let's go ahead and compare them
[Music]
[Applause]
and yep just as i suspected they're
basically identical no difference and i
was hoping that they were gonna get quad
speakers just like the ipad pro has but
unfortunately it doesn't and if you want
to see how much better the ipad pro
speakers are we are going to be doing a
full comparison between the new ipad air
5 and the m1 ipad pro so click subscribe
so you don't miss out on that video and
now it did actually change is the
cameras now on the back you have the
same exact 12 megapixel single camera
but we did get some software updates
which is nice but on the front we have a
massive difference the new ipad air 5
actually comes with the 12 megapixel
ultra wide camera which also supports
center stage so you can use it with
multiple people and it follows your face
around which is nice and now
unfortunately because the 12 megapixel
camera is ultra wide on the new one when
it does show the cropped end version
like you see here you actually lose
quite a bit of detail so you can see in
my hair and my face it's a little bit
more soft which is unfortunate and there
is more noise and i would say that for
an ipad having center stage with
ultrawide is definitely worth it and in
case you're wondering about the
microphone quality here is a quick test
on the ipad air 4 which actually zooms
in quite a bit on your face and now this
right here is of course the ipad air 5
with that ultra wide which definitely
looks a lot better and let me know what
you think about the microphone quality
down in the comment section below and
now for the moment of truth let's go
ahead and get into the performance
comparison and see how the a14 chip on
the old one compares to the brand new
a15 now first of all you see a clock
speed difference from 2.99 to 3.19
that's for the performance cores and the
biggest difference here is that the new
ipad air 5 has double the ram it has
eight gigs instead of four so let's see
if that makes a difference let's run the
cpu benchmark and while the ram is not
going to help actual rot performance
that much it is going to help you keep
apps open longer without them shutting
down so that's definitely nice to have
with a year-over-year upgrade and wow
guys this is why you want to buy the
newer model and i just realized i
actually said a15 of course has the m1
and in terms of the performance for
single core it's seven percent faster so
not that much but the multi-core
70
faster multi-core with the new m1 ipad
air that is just amazing and the reason
the single core score isn't that much
different is because the m1 is based on
the a14 cores and that could actually be
a downside because you have a lot more
performance with the new model but i
think it has the same battery so you
might actually have a little bit less
battery life but i'd say the performance
is definitely worth it and now let's go
ahead and do the graphics test and look
at that we have our scores and this is
just so impressive because we're getting
basically the power of an m1 mac mini or
m1 macbook pro in this thin
ipad air yes it is not throttled at all
compared to the ipad pro so the air is
finally getting it and it's 77 faster
than the old ipad air 4 so man this is
like upgrade worthy and now moving on i
actually do want to test out some gaming
benchmarks like gfx bench metal and i am
going to do the 1440p aztec ruins high
tier off screen test all right the test
is done this is actually something i did
not expect
the m1 ipad air
is over twice as fast as the old a14
ipad air 4 that's 81 fps compared to 40
an even bigger difference compared to
the other tests that we showed like
geekbench and this right here is going
to make sure that any game you throw at
it doesn't matter gentian impact
whatever it's gonna handle it at a solid
60 fps no problems at all and now we
have the moment of truth 3d marks
wildlife extreme in unlimited mode let's
see what differences we have in the fps
stability the heat and other things like
that let's start it and yes this is a
thermal camera right here i'm going to
see the differences in the temps so far
with the ipad air 4 we're looking at 32
degrees celsius
and the ipad 35 degrees celsius it's
definitely
heating up faster look at that still 32
over on the ipad air 4
ipad air 5 36
it is definitely heating up
and using that extra gpu oh 33
right there on the ipad 38
38 compared to 32 still 32 33 man this
thing is not heating up
at all 38 wow just finished all right so
the m1 ipad air 5 is done but we're
still waiting on the old ipad air and
bam there we go basically two times more
graphics performance in wildlife extreme
even though it did heat up quite a bit
it still got that two-time scaling so no
problems there and it did not thermal
throttle down and the display did not
dim so with that said the new m1 ipad
air 5 is definitely a lot faster than
the ipad air 4 but other than that there
aren't really that many differences you
have basically the same display the same
speakers you do have the new usb c port
with the faster 10 gigabit per second
speeds compared to 5 but not really that
much has changed and now that i've
compared all of those different things
let's finally answer the original
question is it worth buying the new ipad
air 5 for 600 or getting the old one for
500 or maybe even 470 renewed using the
link in the description below
well to be completely honest if you
already have the air 4 i would not
upgrade at all yes the performance is
nice but there is one major drawback to
the new ipad air 5 and that is the
display it is limited to 60 hertz yes
just like the old one and to me that is
a very big problem because you're not
really able to use the extra m1
performance because we've been using the
a14 chip in the ipad air 4 and it runs
basically any game that we tested just
fine at 60 fps so no problems there so
all the extra performance you're getting
with the m1 you don't really get to use
like you do with the ipad pro which does
have a 120hz pro motion display which
makes a huge huge difference so because
of the 60hz display on the ipad air 5 i
honestly don't think it's worth buying
over the ipad air 4 for a better deal
because you just can't take advantage of
the m1 chip unless you're doing a lot of
different tasks and to be honest
spending 750 bucks on the m1 ipad pro is
probably the better choice so if you
want to see that full comparison between
the ipad air 5 and the m1 ipad pro then
go ahead and click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and check out one of those two right
over there including the mac studio
teardown thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]